[Music]
Friedman title is New Horizons in
particle physics Terry please
Thank You Francis before I begin my talk
I just want to say a few personal
remarks it's a great pleasure to be here
to help celebrate L&S 46 I entered lab
in 1960 as a young assistant professor
and I can say that my work in my a
development as a physicist would not
have been possible without the help of
support that I received in the
laboratory the laboratory has always has
always been a place which who which
nurtured young people and I found that
to be true when I came here and I must
say I profited greatly from that I would
like to give my gratitude to many people
it's impossible to thank them
individually so I have to give a generic
thanks to the many people who worked in
the laboratory over the years for their
help and their support and for making a
wonderful environment in which one can
carry out science and education in terms
of what I want to talk about today I
want to talk it's very it's a very
difficult topic because I'm talking
about the future the future as always
has a big question mark to it so in a
certain sense we're talking about the
relative new recent coming future the
near future I should say I want to talk
about the new horizons for progress in
experimental physics in general progress
and experimental physics comes from two
general directions one is the direction
of greater precision experiments and the
second is at the Hut be high energy
frontier the talk that I want to give
today will focus primarily on the high
energy frontier and to put my talk in a
certain context I'd like to go back to
1946 the year the laboratory began
these were the particles the so called
elementary particles that existed in
we had the electron and positron the
muon which was just a heavy electron
that was a great mystery in fact Pais in
his book inward bound says it was it was
a case of divine laughter we had the
proton we had the neutron the photon the
neutrino had been predicted but what
wouldn't be discovered for another ten
years the pie the pie medicine had not
yet been discovered it had been
predicted in the in the 30s to explain
what we knew about nuclear forces one
year after the laboratory was born the
pine was discovered here is the George
Clark talked about this here was the
here's that here's a photograph of the
nuclear emulsion the pie comes
indication to a muon and here the the
upper part is the is the muon continuing
now when the pine was discovered there
was a great deal of satisfaction there
was a feeling that somehow this met
expectations
perhaps the picture was becoming
clarified but it was a short-lived point
of view because shortly after that the B
particles were discovered in the cosmic
rays and there was the s particles and
more and more complexity developed and
this complexity came from the discovery
of a large number of new particles and
it was driven primarily by new
technology by the invention of the
synchrotron high-energy accelerators for
in 1952 the cosmic Ron came into
operation new types of detectors the
bubble chamber it was invented in 1952
and these two devices helped drive the
complexity and for example by 1970 the
there already a hundred and forty
baryons listed in the view review of
particle physics apart of the properties
and 30 mesons and this was sort of
monotonically increasing up to that time
now in the 60s and 70s there were some
conceptual developments very important
ones which shaped
our current picture there was su3 which
was which developed a periodic table
strong strongly interacting particles it
was predictive it it predicted particles
which are later discovered there was the
quark model which was the building
blocks of SU three that was in 1964 it's
su3 was in 61
there was the electroweak unification
which related the electromagnetic and
the weak interactions
I must Steve Weinberg who was here did
this work in 1967 when he was a member
of LNS there was quantum chromodynamics
in 1973 which developed the theory of
the interaction of quarks and that in
itself provided the rationale for having
quarks inside hydrants without escaping
it had had the hypothesis of confinement
and also the the asymptotic freedom
which appointed which which basically
explained the weak interactions that the
weak the much weaker interactions that
quarks have a short distances which were
which was in the basis of the impulse
approximation and deep inelastic
scattering this all left at a standard
model which we have today and that is
the following we have three generations
of fermions we two of which we have not
just found yet we have not found the top
quark or the Tau neutrino I should say
that gravity is not part of the standard
model I just put it here just to remind
people that it has to be a condor for
later we do not have a quantum theory of
gravitation here are the the gauge
bosons which carry the forces and this
particular particle the Tau neutrino
doesn't seem to disturb very people
people are very much in the sense that
the decay properties of the Tau lepton
are very well understood and there
though would one would like to see it do
something in a laboratory of people are
not pressing to find it however the top
the top quark is another matter
it is very integral to understanding the
standard model
and one desperately wants to find it
there is one other aspect of this of the
standard model which one has to talk
about and that is spontaneous symmetry
breaking the underlying equations upon
which the standard model is based have
much more symmetry than is observed in
nature the masses are zero and this all
requires a mechanism that breaks these
symmetries and creates mess the standard
standard model unfortunately is not very
specific as to what this exact mechanism
is a special mechanism is assumed namely
the the simplest mechanism which is the
Higgs field what the idea there is
there's that feel which pervades the
entire vacuum the interaction of
fermions with this vacuum it creates the
the creates their masses it also creates
the masses of the gauge bosons and the
quanta of these neutrals of these of
this field our neutral Skater particles
the Higgs particles and of course since
this has been proposed people look for
these particles and as the has been
reported in terms of the Elk Creek l-3
results the higgs mass is less is a
greater I should have it's wrong the
hints mass is greater than 53 GeV from
lept so that's the limit we have there
now what about the top mass well it
turns out because the this top mass is
so integrally embedded in the standard
model for example in various reactions
one calculates the Weinberg angle there
are relevant that their rate of
Corrections the electroweak rate of
Corrections which basically affect it in
various processes they get the same
answer in various processes you must put
in the top mass in the Higgs mass so
therefore you do get consistency in this
particular theory one requires a top
mass a top and one can also determine
the top mass from its constraints for
example here is a fit to the two
essentially the various inputs you get
from leppe data as a
of Higgs mass for example this Higgs
Higgs mass here is a thousand GeV this
is 300 this is 50 and you notice that
here that there's a the top mass
increases with Higgs mass and it's about
it's somewhat above 150 now if one uses
additional data beyond left namely for
example if one uses the math of the mass
of the W from CDF in ûà ûà - and also
one use of neutrino scattering results
one gets a sharper fit and you tend to
get a mass around 150 255 GeV for a
Higgs mass of one TeV and of course what
happens here is that as the Higgs mass
gets lighter the top mass decreases if
you ask the question what is a 95%
confidence level in terms of the upper
limit it's about a hundred and
ninety-five GeV so the Higgs mass I mean
the the top mass is less than a hundred
ninety-five GeV with 95% confidence
level so the Higgs the top mass is now
pretty well limited by this by the
standard model but still one wants to
find it up and one of my stuff on the
top and one wants to measure it because
one has to find consistency in the
standard model
now there's a there has been a search at
firm at the Fermilab collider and which
is continuing and there you have
basically proton and proton collisions
you can make a top at the top pair with
either quark antiquark annihilation or
so-called gluon gluon fusion the top can
be kate will decay into a w and a B the
W then can decay into either
II knew mu new tile new namely the
lepton modes or a QQ bar the cleanest
search mode is the so-called dye leptin
signal where each where the W from the
top and a W from the nth from the
anti-cop will each decay into a lepton
it's extremely clean and the signal to
background is much greater than 10 for
most of the mass region and let me give
you the the latest limit this is this is
a result of the CDF measurements and
this basically has about five inverse
Pico Barnes luminosity integrated the
luminosity and here's the theoretical
resolve for the production of top anthe
top the the this gives you the range of
uncertainty it's given primarily by the
structure functions this is the upper
limit from the using all the dial f x
plus ayby tag and basically were
intersects the lowest theoretical limit
is the region of the lower limit for top
which is 91 GeV now Fermilab is having
as it's now in the midst of an upgrade
which is being it hasn't started in
terms of construction but the plans are
going on and that is the new main
injector and that will increase the
amount of integrated luminosity enormous
leap and by the year around the year
2000 there should be at least a thousand
inverse Pico Barnes with one additional
detector so it'll be a factor of 400
more data available to find
top at Fermilab and this would print
this will permit the top quark to be
seen if its mass is 250 GeV or less
which goes beyond the limit of the
standard model in addition if the one
will be able to measure the top mass
with reasonable precision namely less
than 10 GeV if the lat if the mass is
less than 180 GeV so what can make a
reasonably good measurement of the top
mass in addition I won't talk about the
beat the beep assistant them to be pairs
that can be produced but in addition one
could make a measurement of the W mass
to a precision of fifty MeV or less and
that's comparable to the limits for L 2
L 200 now with this alone
there will be an enormous leap powerful
constraint in the standard model here
I've plotted the mass of the W versus
the mass of the top for various various
higgs masses one thousand five hundred
125 GeV now let's just assume that the
it turns out that the top mass is let's
say a hundred and thirty this is the
limit that one has in terms of the top
mass going horizontally the W mass will
be given in this region this is the
region that will be allowed in terms of
the standard model at that level one is
we'll even be able to get some
information about the scale of the higgs
mass and we'll put enormous constraints
on the standard model in terms of
whether there is physics outside which
can be seen in this particular set of
measurements so by the year 2000 one
hopes that will be enormous ly powerful
constraints on the standard model but
even if a standard model is found to be
correct with no problems there are lots
of questions
the experimental the the standard model
has been experimentally confirmed so far
but is incomplete it has roughly 23
parameters or different ways of County
that's why I say about 23 parameters the
question of symmetry breaking is still a
question what is the mechanism there's a
question of CP violation we know there
CP violation of the standard model can
can account for it because we know that
for with three generations there is a
phase in the phase in the in the theory
which can account for CP violation but
we don't know whether the CP violation
that we observe comes from within the
standard model or outside the student
standard model so it is quite clear the
higher energy experiments are needed to
clarify many of these issues well
there's a there is a new generation of
proton-proton colliders that on the
horizon which will be very important for
searching for the physics beyond the
standard model let me talk about two of
them these two the LHC and the SSC the
energy of the La si will be between
about 15 15 and 16 te v the SSC
basically is 20 on 20 so it this will be
a center of mass energy of 40 the
initial design luminosity for the LHC is
about 3 times 10 to the 34 for the SSC
is 10 to the 33 although it is clear
that with minor upgrades this can this
luminosity can be raised to above 10 to
the 30 for the circumference of the LHC
is 60 miles SSC is 54 miles the dipole
fields that are being contemplated for
the LHC magazine is well is about 10
Tesla for the SSC is about six and six
and a six-and-a-half Tesla
now I'd be in terms of where they are I
should say that this machine is being
planned but it has not been a it is not
going to prove yet this machine is under
construction at the present time let me
just show you a
this shows you the the SSC this is
Dallas this is Forth Worth it's really
something of geographic significance
there's no question about it here I'll
show you again a picture of lept where
the LA scene will be located and we put
an another magnet ring will be put
inside leppe another significantly large
accelerator now let me just show a few
things here is a here's a few loose a
few things I could say about this is the
SSC here's here are comfortable sizes
other machines here's here's lept here's
here's here's a slack here's the
Fermilab Tevatron it turns out that to
get this to get this kind of energy one
needs five stages of acceleration one
starts out with a actually there's even
another one there's a very low ion
source but there's a linic a low energy
booster a medium energy booster a high
energy booster this is a two TV device
it feeds into this machine here are they
here's where the experimental halls will
be on both sides of machine and here is
a a view of the cross-section of the of
the tunnel
now this machine is a formidable machine
from an experimental point of view a
typical event there will be a hundred
million of these per second at ten to
the thirty three luminosity a hundred
million in one has to detect sort and
and store all the relevant events when
one goes to 10 to the 34 when is talking
about billion per second so one is going
to one requires the most sophisticated
and complex instrumentation the highest
levels of fast electronics and enormous
computational facilities to make a
project like this work and this is this
is one of the this is the great
technological challenge of such a
project let me show you there are two
detectors which are now being planned
one is called the SDC and I won't I
don't have time to discuss them in
detail because I want to talk about the
physics this is the SDC and here is the
so-called scale factor this measure this
is an individual person here and this is
the SDC with the various subsystems and
the second detector is called Jem and
let me show you a schematic of that
and here is another person here so you
got some idea of the magnitude of these
detectors just absolutely enormous
they're incredibly complicated things to
build and they take many years now I
also want to show you that civil
construction has has begun there here is
it's a project which is going beyond a
paper project I don't know whether you
can see this so well this is the the
magnet laboratory here which has been
constructed and now has it has all kinds
of magnets being tested in here here are
buildings associated with the with the
compressors and the refrigeration and
the magnetic power supplies magnet power
supplies here is a long structure here
which will be use for a string test of
magnets which will be carried out this
summer the magnets are performing well
in terms of their meeting specifications
and here is a photograph of the spring
of magnets being put there b5 dipoles
and one quadrupole along here each
dipole is 50 feet long
and here is a shaft which is being dug
near that near let's read this near this
area that we've got to just showed you
and this shaft will be used to deliver
the magnets to the tunnel this shaft is
will be 60 feet it'll be an oblong
cross-section 60 feet long and 30 feet
wide and will be 265 feet deep and this
this is the beginning of the of the
digging at this point now let's go and
talk a little bit about what what the
physics will be well one of the major
things that one has to of course look
for is the Higgs because the assumption
is in the top will be discovered at
Fermilab and now the whole question is
is the Higgs the question what is its
mass is it elementary or composite if
it's composite there will be new kinds
of forces and a constituents for example
there's a Technicolor model which
basically has it has a composite Higgs
but if you have a composite Higgs you
have to have new kinds of gluons and new
kinds of quarks and these give rise to a
whole new family of particles called at
which we'll call techne particles that
we techne pons techne rose etc and these
are expected to be at the TV mass range
so these particles are really things
that can be searched for at the SSC so
the thing is one has to both look for
the Higgs and also look for new families
of particles
now you've heard from Gregor hurtin
about how the Higgs is look for there
are various modes let me just repeat
them maybe the two gamma for when the
Higgs is less than the mass of the Z
when is between the Z and the two Z's
you can get a Z plus two leptons which
will go to four leptons if the Higgs is
greater than two Z masses then you get
two Z's and four leptons of course the
cleanest signals are various
combinations of electrons and muons and
of course you measure the kinematics at
the to essentially establish the
invariant mass of the Higgs now there
let me just show you some simulations
here but more to show you about what's
happening with the signal because
there's a very interesting thing that
goes on here
this is for 200 g e V this is for 400 GB
these are simulations made by the SDC
group and this is for 800 GeV you can
still know it's measured at 800 GeV now
what's going on here is the following
it turns out that the higgs mass
basically its width is growing with the
with the value of its mass the the width
of the Higgs goes as the mass cubed so
when the Higgs becomes gets to a mass of
1.4 TeV it disappears as a particle
because its width is equal to its mass
so in a certain sense you were seeing
here the width of the Higgs getting
broader and if you go much higher it
gets more and more difficult to see and
the question is are there other ways of
approaching this problem for example
what happens if the Higgs gets to a mass
of 1.5 it's you cannot find it there's a
particle can you find out anything about
it and this this is a very important
question well it turns out that you can
and this is one of the things which is
really most interesting
let me first say let me before I get to
that question here let me show you the
limits of this basically of discovery in
terms of the SSC this is for an 800 GeV
Higgs now this is the ten thirty ten to
thirty three
is the standard luminosity for the SSC
here is the ultimate luminosity that is
the theoretically up the theoretical
upper limit that one can get to and if
once sticks to the standard luminosity
one Y can just about get to about a TV
with the SSC then of course if you go
beyond that the mass gets so so broad
that you start getting into great
difficulty but you see what happens here
is the following if the if the Higgs
mass gets great comes greater than one
TV it turns out that W W and Z Z and W Z
production will be enhanced and this can
be observed at the SSE is a very clear
signal of something very strange going
on and it would because what's happening
here is that the symmetry breaking force
comes strong it becomes a strong force
and not only will you see enhanced
production of these things you'll also
probably see new particle residences
between the one and three te v level let
me just point out how this comes about
and it there been a number of papers
written on it and I'm certainly not an
expert but I'll just report what what
has been put in the literature if you
looked at the higgs mass it's related to
a unknown parameter called lambda and d
squared where V is the vacuum
expectation of the heat of the Higgs
fields related to the Fermi constant now
turns out lambda represents the self
interaction of the Higgs field so when
lambda gets big the self interaction of
the Higgs field becomes very large so
what happens for it for the Higgs mass
greater than the square root of two V
you get lambda greater than one and
you've got a strong interaction between
these things actually it's between the
longitudinal components of these gauge
bosons and this leads to enhance
production of pairs of gauge bosons and
the process looks very much like this
if you have what happens as a cork comes
here it you you get you get aw aw a
virtual W emitted on both sides you have
a strong interaction here which which
basically represents this is just sort
of this black ball here represents the
nonlinear interactions of the Higgs of
the higgs field and then you get
basically the these things scatter and
become real particles and and you get a
lot of them well not a lot but you get
enough to measure it's gonna be hard to
measure for example here is just for the
Z Z this has been calculated on the
basis of it turns out the calculations
are quite model in the pendant because
they basically make associations with
with low energies PI on scattering
theorems and these are well understood
and for example here is a Z Z signal for
a one TV Higgs now here you see here is
the very broad mass that you would
observe in terms of just the K of the
Higgs and the two Z's here is the
background here is the enhanced Z Z
signal coming from this strong symmetry
breaking interaction so you see right
here you're seeing this effect right
here now most the people who've been
looking and looking at this field that
this background could be estimated to
30% and therefore one can really see the
effect of this enhanced Z gauge boson
pair production
so the point here the point here is that
even if the higgs mass is large enough
so you can't see it as a particle you
will see its effects and I think that's
extremely interesting
now what about supersymmetry
supersymmetry is also something which
would be very appropriate to search for
at the SSC now supersymmetry is a very
attractive point of view theoretically
it it allows one to have a quantum
theory of gravity it allows gravity to
be in to put into some sort of
unification grand unification the idea
here is that particles have
supersymmetric partners for example the
quark which basically a fermions
fermions have bosons and bosons a
fermions and for example the quark spin
1/2 has a squirt which is spin 0 left
time is slept on w as i always want to
say y know but it's really we know and
the the reason that it's it's such a
tractive theory is because when you put
in the superpartner
you get cancellation of infinities and
so that actually many things are
calculable and for and for example it's
it's an integral part of super string
theory for that reason and so it's very
attractive to look for these things now
from an experimentalist point of view
there's not a shred of evidence that
they exist I mean you have yeah it's a
very it's a very perplexing situation
theoretically it's a beautiful idea as
an experimentalist there's nothing to
basically substantiate it
now there's been a little bit of new
information which have given any
proponents of this point of view some
encouragement and that is the question
of grand unification which is a very
cherished idea in particle physics now
it turns out that if you what I'm
plotting here are recent results for the
inverse coupling strengths these are
listed for the strong and the
electroweak and it the thing which is
which has occurred recently because of
the very beautiful work coming out of
left and other places it turns out that
we once were
thought there was unification
unification scale experimentally being
observed it's no longer true if you if
you run these coupling causes as they is
one wants to do so in terms of a minimal
theory they don't meet at one point they
should meet at one point and go on they
should meet at one point then of course
then you have the unification scale but
they're not doing that
and so that has caused some concern now
it turns out that if you take su5 and
you put in a minimal supersymmetric
addition to it you get you get
unification so this is made people ask
the question is this a hint now there
are other thing other features to this
which make it also attractive it raises
the unification energy by a factor of 10
and this has the effect of increasing
the proton lifetime by a factor of 10 to
the fourth which makes the SU 5 super
symmetric model compatible compatible
with the proton lifetime measurements
which is something that I think one
finds very attractive the other thing
about it is that the is that the mass of
the supersymmetric particles into it the
fit indicates that it's in the it's at
the 1tv scale here are the actual fits
and here's here's the here's the fit was
super symmetric addition to it and you
can see this is the S of the cross over
here this is the the mass of the
supersymmetric particles scale which is
a one-to-one TV and here is the where
the unification energy occurs so the
question is is it an accident or is it a
hint at any rate if particles are being
if there's a suggestion that these
particles exist in the 1tv scale it
makes the the SSE a perfect place to
look for these things now
what about the level of of exploration
this is Illuminati required for example
for producing a hundred thousand Louie
no events here is the ultimate
luminosity here is a standard luminosity
at the standard luminosity you can get
to about 1.6 TV for a gluey no now you
see this is the luminosity required for
producing ten thousand gloomy no events
and the point here is that the reason
you want so many is because it's a heart
signal to detect so you want a lot and
so it's a it's conservative its
conservative number any rate in terms of
the ultimate luminosity one can get
probably roughly to about two and a half
TV what about the structure of course
the current measurements indicate that
their point like and their size is less
than ten to minus 17 centimeters how
small are they are they composite the SS
eight will be able to probe a quark
structure down to distances of the order
of less than five times ten to the minus
nineteen centimeters now how is this
done
well the whole idea here is that of
course protons consist of quarks and
gluons and when you have scatter you
scatter a court you have quark quark
scattering quark gluon scattering blue
on blue one and these things basically
hydrolyzed into jets and you measure the
momentum distributions the PT
distributions to provide information
about the structure of quarks now I'd
like to show you a or quark scattering
event from the CDF it's a it's a very
remarkable event it's a beautiful event
here we look here we have pseudo
rapidity and here's the azimuthal angle
and here is basically the energy from
one jet from the other jet if they're
both they're about at 90 degrees back to
back and the reason I say their quarks
is because rather than gluons it because
they said had such a high you arcane X
the X is for these two jets this is
about at about 0.45 and this is about
0.4 so for the so that actually this is
a very good candidate and this shows you
this sort of information this this is
like particle particle scattering that's
the point I'd like to make these this is
this is ver this is a this this is a
quark and so one now how do you see the
effect of composite quarks well if you
scatter one work against another quark
well you can have a standard goo on
exchange if there's a composite Nisour
size in general this term will be
reduced in terms of scattering
probability because they'll be a form
factor however if there are constituents
you have the possibility of exchanging
constituents which adds to the
cross-section you have another channel
to basically to scattered and therefore
this thing will increase the
cross-section it turns out that when the
calculation has been made this effect is
dominant at high transverse momentum and
so therefore in general one gets an
increase in cross-section
and here's for example here is the
scattering cross-section here is the the
transverse momentum in terms of te V
over C now what you do here is you have
you have here's the matrix element
squared here's a point like here's the
matrix of them for point like structure
and there's a a correction term which
has a constant lambda square which
represents the increase in cross section
it's called a composite this parameter
and you sort of you measure this and
this gives you a sense of the scale and
for example for a lambda of 10 T V this
is where this is what the yield should
be 15 20 now if the cross section gets
as high as this you see this would
correspond to saying that the lefty cork
has a size which is a around 10 to the
minus 18 centimeter in general what you
do this is this is now they resolved for
a point like for a point like a cork and
of course the limit is if you if it if
it varies around this particular
prediction here then of course the size
the error will give you the limit and
lambda so the lambda that one can
probably get to is between 25 and 30 TV
with the SSC so one can actually find
out about cork size at least get some
very very good limits on it now of
course we know about the the carriers of
the weak force we have the gauge bosons
the W plus W minus at Z 0 the question
is are there higher mass Z and W
particles one can start very
straightforward to detect at these high
these colliders and at the SSC one will
be sensitive to masses up to ten TeV so
one can search for such heavy gauge
bosons up to 10 te v now I'd like to
just stress one point that I think came
very clearly from Alan Guth talk is that
this these results are very important to
understanding cosmology the SSC energy
densities will will be equivalent to
those roughly 10 to the minus
14 seconds after the Big Bang so
basically you're looking at a very early
time recently early time in the
evolution of the universe in terms of a
Big Bang model the Higgs type a Higgs
type mechanism is employed in the
inflationary model of universe namely
there the idea of having a a false
vacuum initially is very important
because the the phase change to the true
vacuum where the lowest vacuum derived
the inflation so it's very important
that that mechanism be understood many
people have have proposed the lightest
supersymmetric particle as a candidate
for the missing mass of the universe
that's another conjecture but if one
found supersymmetry this would be a very
very important result for cosmology and
in general the detailed scenario of the
development of the early universe
depends on grand unification and
symmetry breaking so basically all our
models of cosmology I think will be
greatly affected by what we learn at
these very high energies so we have very
we have a number of very exciting
searches at both the SSC and the LHC
we're basically L&S groups will be
participating in both I think I
neglected to mention that on the gem
detector we have two L&S groups the
counter spark chamber group and the APC
group and you heard a beautiful talk by
a Gregor hurtin about how the l3
detector is being proposed for a La si
detector so we have many exciting
searches basically to have through which
we will which will be pursued at these
colliders Higgs let me just summarize
them for the Higgs composite this
supersymmetric particles technopark
techni particles new heavy gauge bosons
and new families of quarks and leptons
you see even though we have three
families it's possible for example there
may be other families with massive
neutrinos we don't know but it's a
possibility but I think the thing is if
history is to be a guide if history is
to be a guide it
also maybe that what we what is totally
unexpected maybe the most important
discoveries at these machines the other
has generally been the history of
accelerators so as I was thinking about
the future I was also thinking about
another celebration for the LMS and I
was I thought this is such a wonderful
occasion that I was proposing to have an
Ellen s celebration and called Ellen s60
but if I follow Roman Jacky maybe Jimmy
Ellen s 64 but the point about it
whenever it will lead 60 64 I think
there will be major discoveries from the
SSC and the LHC to present on such an
occasion I think there will be new
theoretical developments beyond the
standard model based upon these
discoveries and I think that L ness as
in the past will be will play a major
role in these contributions thank you
[Applause]